welcome back everybody we've got Bri
Larson with us our new movie is called
the Marvels it's in theaters now and
nowadays nothing says pop culture more
than Marvel movies so it's time for a
pop song trivia game this is Pop Pop
[Music]
[Applause]
Quiz your Jingles are so great okay Lord
can you help us
out he just shows up when I call well
you don't you don't need my help Kelly
you got Captain Marvel over there so
you're in trouble you're in trouble girl
let me tell you got the OG right here I
like it that's right that's what I'm
talking about so here is how the game
works I'm going to read a trivia
question okay and the answer to that
question is hidden in the lyrics of a
popular song So if I asked what was
pulling the open sleigh as the Bells
jingled all the way you might answer one
horse got it no oh my God not at all
perfect perfect okay it's Bri Larson
versus Kelly Clarkson playing for all
the Infinity Stones as well as a prize
for their side of the
audience oh no I don't feel confident
huh it was a lot of no pressure no
pressure at all no pressure I don't I
don't feel confident in neither one of
our skills did this bad like this was
not a good choice okay okay um okay here
we go are you ready no no but oh doesn't
matter cuz we're going anyway question
number one according to a very young
Michael Jackson how easy was
ABC as 1 two three are you that's right
my button is broken my button is
broken that's what I
say do you have like instant replay
because I feel like like that commercial
the red flags yes it's amazing wow you
you really are alike it is true it is
get your hands back away from that okay
okay okay okay they will stay right here
right here where yours are okay okay
okay come on now Bri come on now Focus
here we go get
it I'm trying okay is well pray on it
pray on it girl here's question number
two what time was glattus night's train
leaving for Georgia are you kiding
midnight oh wait
okay glad night that's the most popular
song that I know so you don't have to
finish hearing the question to buzz in
you know we shouldn't explain the rules
that is yeah I like to explain them
after I've won convenient time to tell
me that all right all right all right
that's right she took the train now you
can take a train to Georgia but you
can't take a hot dog because a hot dog
is not a sandwich don't get into that
okay think about it okay here's the next
question I just blew your mind when did
envogue say that you'd be receiving
their
loving to
Tuesday uh I'm sorry that is incorrect
it's it was cute though it was cute I
appreciate it is it never going to get
it never it's never it's never never
never never going to get it never going
to get it I I didn't a trick question I
didn't even understand the question I'm
going to be honest with you you know
what you know what I'm Bri I'm GNA give
you a point just cuz I loved your answer
that thank you you get one point
specifically I got you te don't you
worry ain't never going to get it ain't
never okay so Kelly you got three points
Bri you got one come on Captain together
come on now come on now here's your next
one it would have been nice for George
Michael at the beginning of faith if he
could do what oh touch your body yeah
touch your
[Applause]
body that's a great song and it's nice
it's nice that he asked you know I know
not everybody got a body like you don't
ask enogo he was respectful before we
progressed there exactly go George don't
don't don't be asking invogue though
they'll say no yeah they'll say would be
nice here's your next one so anyway that
sound right there
means it's time for our last question
last question okay and this one is worth
all the Infinity Stones okay this is
worth 40,000
points th000 points yes right okay very
question okay what what very French
question was asked in Lady
Marmalade Mo that's
it and G lson is the superhero today you
congratulations you're my favorite of
course this is my show so you're all
winners of the Kelly Clarkson show with
the holidays right around the corner we
have the perfect gift for the season
Robo Rock S7 Max Ultra Robot vacuum
gives you a handsfree cleaning
experience automatically vacuuming and
moing all one it's also self-washing
drying wow emptying and refilling and
you can control it from your smartphone
that's incredible uh it's like having
your very own housekeeper at home for
the holidays and you're all going home
with a Rubble
off thank you for kicking my behind uh
lessons in chemistry is on Apple TV plus
trust me you do not want to miss it and
also the Marvel is in theaters right now
go check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home oh